[Musique]
notre fille à ce soir avec claire bolduc
et christiane bergevin bonsoir bonsoir
ben ça alors parlons de ces pandora
paper ces nouvelles révélations
de l'utilisation massive par des
célébrités des chefs d'état actuels et
anciens des policiers de sociétés écrans
de prête noms utilisation quand même
massif dont on parle depuis plusieurs
années mais ça existe encore ma foi que
quelle est votre réaction à tout cela
c'est proprement scandaleux si on parle
de l'ucl x on parle de paloma peppers
dont par les fans du rappeur on constate
c pour les non ça fait d'importants
systèmes on a érigé un système
d'évitement fiscal
on a érigé quelque chose qui permet aux
très riches de passer à côté de toutes
les autres contraintes auxquelles une
population normale est soumise dans une
société c'est juste c'est une
législation c'est légal conduite est
légal mais c'est immoral et c'est
honteux c'est juste une législation
complaisante fait par des gens qui
profitent du système
c'est antidémocratique et moi je suis
vraiment choqué et outré de cette sauce
et d'aller construire votre colère
questionne bas je suis aussi jolie mais
surtout attristé et je salue d'abord
travail de tous ces journalistes qui ont
mis en lumière une nouvelle fois cette
situation et c'est sûr que c'est
attristant de penser que des chefs
d'état les mêmes qui ont fait la
promotion des accords de le céder pour
pour limiter l'évitement fiscal on pense
au président poutine qui a accueilli de
givet en 2013 qui a discuté de cette
question là soient les premiers à en
profiter alors on mange à tous les
râteliers c'est le cas de le dire c'est
sûr que le fait que c'est légal qu'on
peut se cacher derrière des conseillers
c'est un sport c'est légal mais en même
temps
tous les gens qui nous écoutent en ce
moment où en tout cas travaille très
fort et leurs impôts qui on se demande
pourquoi les paradis fiscaux sont légaux
christiane c'est ça c'est comme une
drôle de vue de l'esprit que d'accepter
dans notre système qu'on puisse faire de
l'optimisation fiscale
contourner le système en quelque sorte
utilisé des prête-noms des sociétés
écrans pour pas être vu par le fisc dans
son propre pays bas tellement une bonne
question en fait l'action des différents
pays du monde et 139 pays qui ont signé
des accords de cdi est basé sur une
coopération internationale mais on sait
bien que dans la réalité il faut qu'on
ait des actions bilatérales quand on
veut faire lancé un agenda si on prend
juste le canada on a des sociétés
financer des organisations financières
on a des compagnies d'assurance qui qui
sont des concurrents qui ont des
concurrents mondiaux qui s'enregistrent
dans les mêmes marchés alors qu'un
élément de contexte concurrentiel
il ya un élément de volonté politique il
faut le dire et quand on sait que les
3,3 des grands marchés d'investissement
du canada bc les états unis c'est le
royaume uni et c'est le luxembourg au
troisième rang qui a pressé les bas mot
clé barbas a dit que ça dit tout
effectivement est ce que pour que vous
clair est-ce que le lien de confiance
parce que c'est l'état qui décide quand
même est encore une fois altérée par ces
nouvelles révélations
absolument absolument l'état dans un
système de deux poids deux mesures on
dit aux gens de la classe moyenne par
fait passer go payer vos impôts on dit
aux gens très riches qui sont souvent
aussi ce qui influence ces politiques
qui sont eux mêmes partie prenante de
ces décisions-là ondimba et c'est ça
c'est les lois profitez-en taxer et
mettez vous en plein les poches ça goûte
bon ça moi je suis vraiment outrée de ce
phénomène là et tente aussi longtemps
que la consente à la concentration des
pouvoirs forts dans les mains de ceux
qui sont riches et qui profitent des
législations qu'on présente il ya rien
qui va changer alors oui ça ça touche de
façon directe là
la confiance qu'on peut avoir dans une
société démocratique joue soit en
tendres années de nous qu'on a beaucoup
at on entendu dans les reportages sur
pandora paper utilité dans le reportage
de base de frédéric zajac d'hier voici
années de nous très important ensuite de
vous fait de hausse il des bons plans de
son caractère systémique et industriels
et de comprendre qu'il peut fonctionner
grâce au concours des décideurs publics
qui eux écrivent la loi rédige la loi de
façon à rendre légale ce qui ne devrait
pas l'être
qu'est ce que le canada ne fait pas
partie du problème à ce que le canada se
traîne les pieds en matière de fiscalité
internationale
banqueter deux côtés il ya eu des
avancées mais pas très rapide on sait
que le canada à supporter ça puis c'est
tentant de le céder que l' agence du
revenu canadien a aussi établi des
ententes avec plusieurs pays devant une
vingtaine de paradis fiscaux pour
échanger de l'information mais ça
imaginez c'est du travail de moine en
faut aller chercher l'information
goutte à goutte je pense que le fait
qu'ils ont intérêt à émuler davantage le
québec mais surtout à créer si on le
veut finalement un contexte clair
succinct de loi qui fasse en sorte que
les conseillers financiers que les
bureaux comptables tout ça soit que tout
le monde soit pousse dans la même
direction on voit des images pendant que
vous parlez de nos banques canadiennes
dans des lieux paradisiaques et très
chaud parce qu'effectivement les banques
canadiennes sont installés aux îles
turques et caïques high cost notamment
oui il faut dire aussi qu'il ya des
activités légitimes et puis je pense que
la divulgation que l' ocde demande pays
par pays est très évidente si on a 70
personnes qui font des services
financiers des services d'assurance on a
une base d'opération et ça c'est
légitime c'est peut-être la principale
mesure qui était dans ta ce moment ainsi
que les sociétés canadiennes doivent
divulguer pays par pays selon les règles
de l'oecd e et qu'en plus les conseils
d'administration est prête attention
mais sa couv pas les sociétés privées
évidemment est-ce qu'on est dans des
portes tournantes claire entre les
pouvoirs politiques et les milieux
d'affaires les banques et cabinets
comptables
tu m'as fait on est dans des portes
tournantes et ont laissé
leur remplace l'autre ci en est un qui
tombe il y en aura un qui va le
remplacer on est dans un système et
s'est établi un système s'est organisé
ce même légaliser si immoral que ce soit
c'est un système et c'est un système qui
couvre plusieurs plusieurs pays
je suis au commerce c'est vraiment faut
vraiment avoir un regard très critique
sur ce qui ce passe comme population et
comme société question belge aurait un
petit bémol que je pas comme quand
peut-être que c'est d'organiser de façon
systématique je pense qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de progrès mais c'est certain
qu'il ya au moins ce tourniquet c'est
pas une pente tournant vous appelez un
tourniquet
[Musique]
non c'est une porte tournante carrément
qu' il y en a un qui tendent l'autre
remplace c'est aussi simple que ça c'est
ainsi aussi longtemps que nos policiers
sont complaisants face aux soeurs et
tacle aussi longtemps qu'ils en
profiteront humain n y aura pas de
changement c'est long il faut jouer mais
dans les politiques et raptor est ce que
toutes les situations sont comparables
est-ce que c'est plus grave que des
décideurs politiques profitent des
paradis fiscaux par rapport à des
célébrités dont on parle de jacques
villeneuve ou de shakira ou john quand
on a des présidents de pays des premiers
ministres premiers niche tchèque
notamment qui qui eux font aussi de la
lutte contre la corruption leur cheval
de bataille
vos réactions à chacune questionne les
leaders politiques c'est comme des chefs
cuisiniers en connaissent les
ingrédients de la recette et c'est le
même blâme mais certainement que dans
leur cas ils peuvent pas prétexter que
c'est leur conseiller et à ce titre
quand on est le leader politique on doit
donner l'exemple alors je dirais que le
blanc mais double clair
c'est peu importe c'est inacceptable
mais pour les chefs politiques c'est eux
qui établissent les règles des
conditions qui vont imposer à leurs
populations et à leurs travailleurs de
payer les impôts et des taxes alors
lui-même ce système cette obligation là
et qu'ils sont d'évitement fiscal c'est
jacques avetisyan la hotte est double
mais à tout point de vue c'est
inacceptable peu importe si
j'allais dire peut-être qu est ce qu il
faut créer c'est un contexte de la
coalition des bises
intentionnés à ce que les conseillers
financiers pourraient pas avoir un code
de conduite annuel est ce qui pourrait
pas certifié annuellement qu'ils ne font
pas de transaction appuyant directement
ou indirectement les paradis fiscaux et
je pense que ça ce serait d'un pour les
athlètes sa dent pour les célébrités
parce que personne ne veut s'associer
une firme finalement qui qui joue sur
les deux tableaux excellent merci merci
pour votre regard avisé sur ce segment
est simplement une dernière phrase c'est
actuellement le fait que les pandores
après pas mettre de l'avant des
personnes expliquent qu'ils ont joué
dans ce contexte là c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de racheter cesse son honneur
d'en acheter sa réputation que ce qu'on
peut perdre en impôts et je vous parie
qu'il ya des gens qui vont être très
très très offusqué que leurs noms soient
publiquement dénonçé clair merci
christiane merci beaucoup à la semaine
prochaine à la semaine prochaine pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit